can we move on now to quarterback hand
size you know that's an important metric
for quarterbacks really and here's the
thing
there is some relevance there and there
has to be some connection guys like
dante culpepper who was a giant yeah but
his hands were smaller than mine right
he couldn't hold on to the football dave
craig couldn't hold on to the football
his hands were small in your perspective
and from your experience how relevant is
this question of how big a guy's hand is
or is okay well there is some positives
certainly you know and more times than
not guys who would you know hey aaron
rodgers tom brady those guys got big
hands but that helps certainly and the
biggest thing is in weather conditions
right that's where you've really seen
the talk more times than not the one
thing i learned in new england is you
had to have a certain hand size for them
to really even put you on the radar at
the quarterback position now how big
what's the minimum yeah i i want to say
it was like nine nine and three quarter
minimum i want to say it was around
there it might have been a hair bigger
than that i might be a little a little
off there i can't remember exactly so so
joe burrow has nine inch hands right he
would be off the board yeah he would
certainly be awesome he wouldn't be off
the board but he would have a deficiency
or a red mark next to him as far as like
height weight speed deficiency that you
know they don't love but i think there's
a few things to talk about here and i
want to talk about this here's a little
football and i throw matt casey because
you know i really think within the last
you know five ten years as we've seen
football blow up right and the sport has
continued to um you know grow younger
wise where guys like patrick mahomes are
playing seven on seven football in
seventh grade and throwing the ball a
million times all right so traditional
hand grips right
more times than not here i'm a two and
five guy if anybody could what does two
and five mean two right here that second
notch right that second notch where am i
at right there see that's two and then
three four five so my ring finger's on
two and my pinky finger goes on the
fifth the fifth little gap there okay
people are all over the place
traditionally you see two and five john
elway was two and four dan marino was
two and five uh tom brady is one in four
what i've seen where i think it means
less of a difference now in this day and
age in the nfl and i'm amazed by this is
how guys like patrick mahomes
and kyler murray
and who else lamar jackson how they grip
the ball they've really from compared to
the old school guys were like aaron
rodgers and brett favre was three and
under six like this can you imagine that
right there you know that's how big his
hand is and of course i have a really
big hand and i can do it too ten and a
half inches ten and a half inches i know
i think i had the second biggest hand
hands at the combine but where it's
different now is the quarterbacks
especially the guys with the smaller
hands are grabbing the smaller part of
the ball up here so you're seeing a lot
of like one and three or one in four
grips where you know now you're not
getting to the fat part of the ball and
i think it's less of an issue i don't
think people kind of messed around with
these kind of hint uh you know grips in
the 80s and early 90s it's kind of taken
this new form about it so you can
compensate you can compensate for having
smaller hands by just putting your hand
up the ball closer to the at the part of
the ball where it's holder hold on it's
it's so low tech i know but it's so
simple it is like if you have a big hand
you can grip the big part of the sure if
you have a tiny little hand you can just
grip down here now i don't i wouldn't
recommend no no laces that would be a
difficult throwing motion but but i i
get your point and uh so joe burrow nine
inch hands no big deal we've seen him
play it's not like he's got a fumbling
problem it'd be different if he had a
fumbling problem and then you measure
his hand you say well now we know why he
has a fumbling yeah right here's the
thing though college football a little
bit smaller definitely nfl how big of a
factor is that yeah he'll have to toy
with it a little bit you know he might
he might you know i know my father was a
two and five guy and then got to the nfl
and switched to two and four a little
bit because of the you know the fatness
of the football so again this is not an
alarming thing for joe burrow i've seen
enough throws for john burrow to go guy
can throw it he can throw it anywhere on
the field he can throw perfect spirals
now will
what will he did play in the sec where
the weather is pretty good every week
right so i would bet some teams test
them out a little bit with the wet ball
drill things like that hey let me dunk
the ball in here let me just see 10
throws just to see if you can manage it
that way and then yeah there'll be
questions about his ability to throw the
ball in really cold weather now i think
a lot of that will be like what wiped
away because in ohio kid too and that'll
help out the the argument to that but i
don't think it's an issue either way and
we've seen patrick mahomes playing
weather he holds the ball like one and
three or one and four really at that
small part and it's like a baseball in
his hand i can't throw it like that i
can't do it it sticks in my hand almost
but it gives him great control great
power and believe it or not yeah back in
the day people didn't like experiment
with their grips as much as they do now
and i think that's why we're seeing you
know more smaller quarterbacks smaller
hands and it just doesn't matter because
they've thrown enough balls in seven on
seven in high school football to figure
out the grip they like and still make it
work and spin and throw with power joe
burrow at least has a sense of humor
about his tiny little minuscule hands
you have to twitter to say considering
retirement after i was informed the
football will be slipping out of my tiny
hands please keep me in your thoughts
patrick holmes responded by saying my
small hands are doing all right so far i
believe in you but my home's nine and a
quarter that's a full quarter inch
bigger yes than burrow and when we
measure that right it's the you spread
out your hand tip of the thumb to the
tip of the pinky that's how they get
that measurement no i think that's wrong
too i would adjust that if i'm the nfl
what would you do well because i think
that this is like here's my my case in
point would be somebody like you know
aaron rodgers all right just for
instance there i think my hand measures
out bigger than him at the nfl combine
my hand is not as big as aaron rodgers
my hand is bigger than his from from
here from my you know thumb to the pinky
like you mentioned i have a really big
palm but when i shook aaron rodgers
hands and i've seen his hands his
fingers are this long to me i would
start measuring from the tip of the
middle finger down to the bottom of the
the start of the wrist or the bottom of
the palm there to me that's more
relevant in the grip itself because
again what does it really matter people
move their thumb all over the place so
it doesn't really matter how that grip
is yeah i lock it in there but i've seen
some great quarterbacks who put it up
there and do that and they don't really
worry about grabbing the whole fatness
of the ball necessarily how much of that
actually changes over time or how much
of it is a function of that's the way
the guy grabbed the football the first
time he ever picked it up and throw it
yeah i think a lot of it is that way it
is a little bit and then i think from
there you go to tinkering you know i i
tinkered at times where you know okay i
want to put more of my finger on the on
the laces oh i want to you know have it
a little bit more finger tippy and then
i did mess around with you know two and
five and then three and six i you know
it just because i would go through a a
cold spell throwing the ball back man i
just don't feel good not throwing
perfect spirals not throwing the ball
away i want you know i don't know the
ball just feels weird and i would tinker
with my grip and mess with it but really
end up always reverting back to what my
natural grip was we've heard before talk
about how players will try to change
their mechanics but then when they get
into the fray right the muscle memory
takes over again how hard is it to
consciously remember to grip a ball
differently if you're trying to tinker
with you very hard
it's going to take you know a few weeks
of reps i think to grab it naturally or
you're going to be dropping back and
instead of reading a coverage or
something you're going to be thinking
about oh is my hand in the right place i
know i've i've messed with that too when
i played in tampa and i just told you i
was tinkering with my my uh my grip at
one point where i found myself i was
going damn i'm i'm thinking about the
wrong thing here as i'm dropping back to
pass i can't do that so it is something
that would take a full off-season i know
you have a snarky joke to me no i'm just
thinking i'm i'm imagining between
thinking about the grip of the football
yeah your drops
your reads right your mechanics right
and having john green
constantly pestering hurry hurry he's
open he's open no he's not shut up
you're the coach
shut up
and look as we've talked about this
before it gets you ready for
the fray it does it and because if it's
harder in practice than it's going to be
during a game you're going to be ready
for a game yeah that's right and this is
going to be a lot of these quarterbacks
first experience into the fray because
some of these meetings they'll go
through this week are going to be about
you know we all know it's 10 15 minute
meetings right the pressure's on they
want to get a lot accomplished and they
want to rattle especially the
quarterback they want to put them under
the pressure a little bit whether it's
at the chalkboard going through checks
hey we're going to teach you this real
quick now teach it back to us uh and
that's part of you know what you're
saying the beauty of a coach trying to
see how we react a player reacts under
pressure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports